Chloe Arnold:
One. two, three, four.
Choreographer:
One. two, three!
Chloe Arnold:
Ahh!
(Clap!)
Ryan, Will, and Octavia were so
open to learning the
choreography, that they went all in.
♪♪
Chloe Arnold:
Lean and- that's it!
Yes, right before the end.
Rooster! Don’t- don’t try to
neuter the rooster, okay?
♪♪
Chloe Arnold:
They practiced hard.
You’ll see the
challenge of how tap dance is so complicated
but then simultaneously how
rewarding it is when they got
it.
♪♪
Chloe Arnold:
(Laughs) Yeah.
♪♪
Chloe Arnold:
Yes!
♪♪
Ryan Reynolds:
That is spectacular.
Your socks really bring
the whole look together.
♪♪
Octavia Spencer:
Ahh!
Chloe Arnold:
Yes!
Something really magical!
-I don't even know.
We’re coming for y'all...
♪We’re bringing back Christmas!♪
In the end, they gave every bit
of their soul into this.
Scrooge:
♪Plus a ton of cash!♪
Scrooge & Spirited Ensemble:
♪From some good ol’ fashion
trees!♪
♪♪